hey what up there friends so this video
is a little bit of an experiment I get
lots and lots and lots of requests from
people asking me to flow out to their
favorite songs and I think I have found
a way to honor at least some of those
requests um I'm going to start doing
regular flow videos where I allow people
to suggest music to me and I have my
patreon supporters vote to have me
choose which song that I'm going to
perform to um so this will be the first
of those videos uh it's a little cold
out today so I'll be flowing inside
rather than outside in my little home
studio I hope that's okay I set it up so
hopefully it look still looks pretty out
there um I had my patreon supporters
suggest a series of songs and then vote
on them uh and if you would like to get
involved in suggesting or voting for
those songs in future installments of
this video series stick around to the
end and I will tell you how you can do
that but for right now uh there is
currently a tie between
uh sagon or Sean by Nightwish and please
please please by Sabrina Carpenter to be
the song that I start this series with
so I'm going to break the tie with a
coin
toss and if it's heads it will be night
wish and if it's Tails it'll be Sabrina
Carpenter and of course I dropped it but
it came up tails in the end so please
please please by Sabrina
Carpenter here we go
I have done no prep for this whatsoever
so we'll see what comes out of it shall
we
[Applause]
and I'll be doing this with a brand new
set of sock po I will include a link to
where you can pick up a set of your own
down in the
description but for right
now awesome let me set the mic down
I know I have good judgment I know I
have good taste it's funny and it's
ironic that only I feel that way I
promise them that you're different and
everyone makes mistakes but just
don't I heard that you're an actor so
act like a standup guy whatever Devil's
inside you don't let them out tonight I
tell them it's just your culture and
everyone rolls their eyes yeah I
know all I'm asking baby please please
please don't prove I'm
right please please please don't bring
me to tears when I just did my makeup so
nice heartbreak is one thing my Eagles
another I beg you don't embarrass me
[Music]
please please
please I have a fun idea babe maybe just
stay inside I know you're craving some
fresh air but the ceiling fan is so nice
and we could live so happily if no one
knows that you're with me I'm just
kidding but really really really please
please please don't Pro
on please please please don't bring me
to tears when I just did my makeup so Li
heart is one my e
another you don't embarrass me
[Music]
please please
please if you want to go and be stupid
don't do it in front of
me you don't want to CED of my mus music
don't make me hate you
perally please please please please
please
[Music]
pleasee cool that was
fun all right so if you would like to
get on this train uh you can suggest a
song for me to flow to down in the
comments and uh I will go ahead and put
up a poll on my patreon that will
include your suggestions for my patreon
supporters to vote on for the next
installment of this video series and if
you want to vote on future songs that I
perform to in this series uh you can go
ahead and sign up at the $5 level over
on my patreon I'll include a link to
that down in the description but for
right now um thanks be to the Friends of
the channel uh big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys um pyro
terly toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
uh you can learn more about all these
awesome businesses by checking out the
links that I have down in the
description of this video and uh special
thanks to the non- business friend to
the channel That is Becca Becken thank
you one and all for supporting my
channel um and also too this video and
the videos on this channel would not
exist were not for the amazing support I
get from my supporters on patreon thank
you one and all you're awesome and in
particular I want to thank my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you thank you thank you uh and
if you would like to be able to vote on
future songs that I perform to as well
as uh getting your name in the credits
and a whole host of other rewards uh you
can go ahead and check out my patreon
over at
patreon.com Drex Factor poy and sign up
uh thank you so much in advance for that
and thank you for supporting my mission
to bring po spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world for right now it is
time for me to chill out a little bit I
hope you all enjoyed this and I can't
wait to see what songs you suggest to me
in the future uh I'll go ahead and
include a link to uh other flow videos
that I've done
uh down in the description as well as up
on screen for right now make sure to get
out and flow yourselves and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace
[Music]